[Music]  foreign  [Music]  she was here when she was young  we're the only people staying here I  don't know  [Music]  there was a sound I'm sure other people  have mentioned it to you  I mean  that's strange because nobody else has  mentioned anything at all  [Music]  it's brother here memories flood  quietly in the evening through the  building and on the grounds hello  and I suppose it is a way of staying in  touch  the longer we're here the more it comes  back  that's right what kind of dread  foreign  memories that's what rooms do they hold  these stories some of them are  uncomfortable  we're here now  and that was then  I'm sure I feel I have a right to do  such a thing it feels like trespassing  [Music]  happy birthday Mom to us  [Music]